changement de tripes élections
municipales dimanche dernier beaucoup
d'hommes politiques qui ont des
problèmes avec la justice ou même qu'ils
sont toujours en mis en examen ont gagné
ou ont perdu de justesse c'est le cas de
jean tiberi dans le cinquième de mellick
monsieur mellick qui est en tête au
premier tour à béthune qui a pas été élu
mais deux d'une soixantaine de voix
françois bernardini à istres andré
labarrère à pau jean-jacques de peretti
à sarlat christian nucci du quart fausse
développement un bon repère
gilles catoire à clichy alain juppé à
bordeaux dsk dominique strauss kahn à
sarcelles
robert hue à montigny-lès-cormeilles ça
fait quand même beaucoup de gens et
certains ont rappelé à la prime à la
casse roll c'est à dire que finalement
le fait d'avoir des problèmes avec la
justice n'a pas empêché tous ces hommes
politiques d'être réélue dimanche et
pour en parler ce soir avec nous l'un
des plus contestées voici patrick
balkany la maison
patrick balkany bonsoir alessandra
martinez eric et ramzy michèle bernier
vous connaissez tous le monde
donc vous avez gagné les municipales à
levallois avec 8 points de plus que
votre adversaire olivier de chazeaux
malgré comme je le disais donc une
condamnation à 15 mois de prison avec
sursis et 2 ans d'inégibilité pour avoir
employé des agents de la mairie
chez vous à l'époque vous étiez maire de
levallois employez des gens qui étaient
des salariés de la mairie dans votre
dans votre appartement et vous avez été
reconnue comptable de fait c'est à dire
que donc c'est votre responsabilité est
d'ailleurs vous devez encore enfin vous
nous direz ce que vous en pensez mais
vous devez encore 3,4 millions de francs
à la commune de levallois voilà en plus
de ça faisait toujours mis en examen
dans la sphère des hlm des
hauts-de-seine pour trafic d'influencé
voilà alors répondez sur les deux faces
et le chef d'accusation d' habillage à 1
d'abord en ce qui concerne le personnel
c'était du personnel que je prenais
effectivement à la berri comme je
recevais des investisseurs des gens dont
on avait besoin levallois c'était pas
pour mon usage personnel
car ce que je préfère au monde s'émeut
mettre le samedi soir avec un plateau
devant la télé pour regarder tout le
monde en parle j'en tire et voilà alors
mais va lui ressemble et en plus c'est
bien je me mets en noir parité et l
affaire du trafic d'influencé dans les
hlm non je vous sais c'est une très
vieille histoire
les hlm dès qu'on parlait des hlm on
mettait tout le monde en examen alors
quand j'étais président d'un des plus
gros office de france
on m'a mis en examen c'est vrai pour
complicité de trafic d'influencé je ne
sais pas qui a fait du trafic
d'influencé je ne sais pas de quoi je
suis complice mais il ya très longtemps
et j'en ai plus jamais entendu parler
donc vous vous dites je suis blanc comme
neige quoi j'ai fait une erreur avec le
personnel communal effectivement parce
que j'ai pas pris une délibération
je n'ai municipal vous avez dit vous
pouvez les prendre la voie ça voyez pas
exactement je dois dire que ça c'est ma
faute je n'ai pas fait voter une
délibération au conseil d'ami cipal que
tout le monde dort et faut bien
d'ailleurs son lancement c'est quoi est
ce qu'on appelle la prime à la casse
roll c'est à dire le fait que tous les
gens que j'ai cités là en commençant
tous eu des problèmes avec la justice et
est réélu ou battu de justesse quoi je
crois que ça n'a rien à voir
vous avez des gens qui sont proches de
leurs populations qui sont aimés par la
population qui sont bon maire et vous en
avez qui sont mauvais mère j'ai été
pendant douze ans maire de levallois de
83,95 exactement ensuite j'ai eu six ans
de vacance est à peu près et mon
successeur
eh bien il n'a pas accroché avec la
population il a il n'y a pas eu
d'histoire
bon il m'a attaqué moindre ça a pas plus
ça n'a pas du tout plu aux aux gens et
les levalloisiens aurait préféré qu'ils
s'occupent d'eux plutôt que de s'occuper
de moi
moi je me suis toujours occupé d'eux et
c'est ce qu'ils apprécient et maintenant
ils demandent mais que le maire revienne
série mentalist qui est simple escape à
un repli le cal des gens par rapport à
la république des juges je crois qu'il
faut pas généraliser
il faut pas généraliser les maires sont
des gens en général qui sont très
proches de leur population
c'est la catégorie politique la plus
aimée en france où le voyez dans tous
les sondages
les gens aiment bien leur mère avec les
clowns si c'est vrai c'est des préférés
des enfants
oui oui mais finalement il ya plus de
mer que de clown
[Rires]
matri donc vous dites moi je suis
réhabiliter deux façons par le suffrage
universel et quand le je crois et c'est
très empressé d anciens démocratie ouais
quand le préfet des hauts-de-seine
conteste votre élection vous dites c'est
insultant pour suffrage universel
absolument quand même bon vous dites
c'est quand même bon c'est sûr quelqu'un
qui a fauté par rapport à la société
s'il est élu au suffrage universel ça
fasse sa faute non comme vous avez fauté
c'est comme votre permis de conduire
quand on vous l'enlève pour un mois on
vous l'enlève pas pour toute la vie oui
moi j'ai eu deux ans d'inéligibilité en
on est en 2001 et aujourd'hui il ya
quelques mois quand je suis revenu le
maire a dit ah ben je vais appeler la
cour des comptes dans le fond il
pourrait peut-être nous redonner encore
un peu d'argent et puis on va leur
condamné une deuxième fois en france y'a
pas de double peine en europe non plus
quand vous avez été condamné pour un
fait d'accord vous ne pouvez pas être
con belge et psg envoie voilà non
seulement j'ai berri avait jeté lui bon
voilà bon et j'ai payer des dommages et
intérêts à la ville et j'ai été
lourdement imposé car en plus on a pris
ça en avantages en nature
vous êtes obligés de mon appartement oui
on va en parler alors vous avez été élu
sans étiquette un dvd ce qui est un vrai
droit juste un divers droite dans les
voter évidemment ça c'est moderne comme
truc alors que chazot votre concurrent
du rpr lui les repères officielle et
puis en plus c'est l'ami de mam de
michèle alliot marie dans celle des
services à je ne sais pas c'est une
femme charmante au demeurant mais il
avait effectivement toutes les avais
c'est à l'interview mensonge là ils
avaient toutes les investitures tour f
ça lui a pas servi à grand-chose à sept
mois qu'on puisse dire et y en a
d'autres je vous accuse de clientélisme
et de populisme c'est vrai que tous ces
maires qui sont très aimée c'est souvent
parce qu'ils font du clientélisme d'un
squale clientélisme
si c'est s'occuper des gens quand ils
ont un problème quand ils ont un
problème d'appartements quand ils ont un
problème d'emploi mais oui alors ça je
suis pour
alain barrière un barrière bravo je suis
pas le meilleur service mais déjà vous
commencez bien jour pas sur le public un
soulier patrick balkany qui était en 48
à neuilly sur seine
votre père s'appelait joola c'est ça
joue la wii immigrés juifs hongrois
résistants des bractées il a fait
fortune dans prêt-à-porter de luxe
raisonnable des magasins vêti et je me
souvienne ça il veut dire nature
publicitaire rétine
absolument très marqué mon enfance à
l'arrivée du magasin de champs elysées
faubourg saint-honoré et vous est ce
qu'on peut dire c'est un petit peu un
fils à papa non oui sauf que jettera
j'ai commencé par travailler dans le
prêt-à-porter annoncé commencer à
écouter oui absolument
pour trouver un boulot une autre étape
en deux ans j'ai pas j'ai pas galérer
voilà les mots lancés dans les pensions
plutôt sélect collège du monde celle
jouy en josas selon vous partager une
chambre avec michel sardou henri iv en
même comment s'étaient alors abstenus
fugain la semaine dernière qui nous
faisait parler d'aller après et après on
était avec fugain ou cours de comédie
c'est ça c'est une bande de potes oui
absolument
après c'était dans un lycée privé en
suisse oui effectivement vous avez fait
un cours d'art dramatique
vous êtes débrouiller pour faire du
cinéma exact il faisait jouer dans j'ai
tué rasputin ont séché il faisait le
grand duc dimitri
ah ben voilà c'est un film de robert
hossein en février le comédien n'est pas
oui mais il est resté en quelque sorte
sauf que je joue mon propre texte inclus
voilà et puis alors après une fête de
service militaire
hélas il était un petit peu pistonné
pour entrer là j'ai eu un gros coup de
poing je suis arrivée à l'elysée un peu
par hasard
ouais voilà je suis passé du bourget à
l'elysée mais classement vous êtes prêt
à l'elysée on parce que mon père avait
des copains nelly et cetera bon et puis
c'est vrai qu'un métis était en face de
l'elysée
voilà alors vous êtes donc au service de
presse de la présidence pendant la
présidence de georges pompidou
absolument que je salue ici genre si tu
nous regardes et donc vous portez vous
portez les dépêches
mais maintenant dans votre curriculum
vitae vous dit vous êtes passés au
cabinet de georges pompidou
quand même enrichie en j'ai toujours
faire j'ai toujours dit que j'avais fait
mon service militaire à l'elysée gt gt
très heureux parce qu'à 22 ans est vrai
que je faisais la revue de presse un
président de la république et que toutes
les heures j'amenais les dépêches de
toutes les agences de presse c'était
c'est un service somme toute très
sympathique et qui vous ouvre des
perspectives c'est vrai donc jusque là
pas trop de problèmes voilà une vie
plutôt sympa et leur a pris le service
vous rencontré celle qui est devenue
votre femme isabelle smadja donc est une
fille d'une famille assez fortunée aussi
oui on peut le dire
familier à soustelle lazareff son nom
que j'étais le patron de combat voilà
déjà et donc ça vous permet quand même
d'accéder assez vite au comité central
du rpr au moment de la création 76 77
gt gt dans les 100 premiers membres du
groupe central oui alors donc pasqua
vous vous remarque cette époque et vous
devenez ce qu'on appelle un pasqua boys
ça fait envie c'est à dire que charles
pasqua a donné leur chance à beaucoup de
jeunes 23 qui ont été élus dans un
certain nombre de cantons à 3 est élu
donc à levallois au municipal maire de
levallois absolue réélu en 89
vous êtes député en 88 et vous resterai
maire de levallois jusqu'en 95 voix des
députés jusqu'à 90 voilà exactement il
est sympa
alors quand vous êtes maire de levallois
vous vous transformez que cette banlieue
populaire en une espèce de nuit coincés
c'est pas une espèce de neuilly c'est
une ville où il ya cinquante cinq mille
habitants et 50000 emplois parce que
quand je suis arrivé dans la ville il y
avait que des usines qui était en train
de péricliter il y avait les usines de
deux chevaux citroën était en train de
fermer
et pour l'économie de la ville il a
fallu faire venir des entreprises se
battre avec les pouvoirs publics pour
construire des des bureaux des logements
des équipements tout genre et je les
fais pendant 12 ans et je crois que les
levalloisiens on était très heureux de
toute cette transformation la preuve
c'est qu'ils viennent de vous relire
donc voilà bon hein vous créer une
police municipale
oui alors il avait on les appelait les
cowboys c'est vrai oui et non c'était la
première police municipale qui a été
créée en ile de france voilà déjà les
357 magnum chef des armées c'est normal
mais ils sont tous armés c'est pour la
sécurité et on a créé aussi la
vidéosurveillance
oui on a été aussi les premiers et
maintenant tout le monde réclame et des
polices municipales
c'est cela qui ont d'ailleurs c'est
assez horrible des caméras partout il y
en a partout et difficile aussi
regardez vous avez le choix de vie en
asie
une balade à levallois au petit fils
mais au moins on n'est pas agressé comme
ça je suis pas sûr que ce soit vraiment
le remède progresser vous avez j'habite
à gennevilliers à chaque fois je
traversais levallois j'avais peur de me
faire agresser par votre police
municipale ait jamais rien fait moi
aussi j'habite là bas en tout cas vous
avez été condamné en attendant donc nous
pour l'instant ça va quoi la 5000
courent plus vite
sa valeur sa main
ça va lancer
valence bien non ce qu'on peut dire
quand même si vous êtes transformé un
peu le valoir une sorte de monaco n'ont
qu'à une espèce de petit endroit comme
ça sur protéger non mais c'est vrai
c'est un c'est une ville où il fait bon
vivre
ouais faut qu'ils croient sécurité ça
dépend de quel jeu des barrières alors
vous achetez donc un appartement fin 500
m² en face de la mairie construite alors
j'ai quitté neuilly pour partir à
levallois où elle est mais quand ils ont
construit mais vous est réservé et un
duplex de 500 mètres car on avait un
appartement à neuilly et les vendus on a
racheté à levallois comme tout le monde
c'est là où travailler donc les fameuses
employés municipaux qui vous ont été
tellement ils sont choyés municipaux
venait m'aider lorsque j'avais besoin
d'eux voilà là il ya un problème c'est
que le juge halphen fameux juge halphen
s'intéresse aux hlm des hauts-de-seine
et surtout au directeur de l'office des
hlm des hauts-de-seine didier schuller
là il sombre histoire où le beau père du
juge halphen monsieur maréchal est mêlé
à une tentative de chantage sur schuller
enfin c'est ce que vous en tous les cas
vous accréditer comme thèse vous dites
je ne sais pas lequel des deux donc
entre schuller et halphen risque le plus
la prison écoutez c'est de la très
vieille histoire histoire c'est une
preuve qu'elles sont par exemple des
histoires regarder traquons il s'en suit
une très vieille histoire qui est tombée
c'est visiblement une histoire de
famille maréchal way et halphen beau
père elle juge moi je suis jamais
rentrer là dedans
ouais en tous les cas le juge a été dans
un premier temps dessaisi du dossier le
jura la scène à cause de cette affaire
maréchal et puis plus tard il a quand
même été lavé de tout soupçon c'est à
dire qu'il ya eu une annulation de la
procédure
voilà tout simplement vous pensez qu'il
y avait vraiment un vrai problème pensez
pas que c'est un montage total ah non
absolument pas ah bon absolument pas non
parce que votre ami schuller lui par
auberge à ce nom je crois qu'il a eu
très peur et la peur obama bah oui tu
veux chez moi où les parts et ça c'était
si beau que c'est bien c'était le
directeur de l'office de hlm des
hauts-de-seine et lui il est parti aux
bahamas
quand il a vu arriver tout ça et ensuite
quand vous perdez la mairie en 95 et
vous êtes condamné lui vous balance
quand même sous leur nom je ne sais pas
j'ai jamais une nouvelle vous savez
malheureusement il n'est pas revenu ou
malheureusement il est parti il n'aurait
jamais dû partir des demi-finales
heureusement sérieusement non
sérieusement parce que je crois que il
ya vraiment pas grand chose dans l'est
dans les dossiers c'est pas l'affairé
elf
après vous vous êtes déprimé avec votre
femme donc ça s'arrange pas vous séparer
pendant un an
oui mais vous savez dans un couple ça
fait 25 ans qu'on est marié temps en
temps j'ai pris la petite clé et vous
n'avez mélangeons pas tout même si elle
est en prison c'est quasiment
aujourd'hui la changer de femme sait pas
combien de fois moi j'ai toujours la
même
avez vous ai repris la même après la
marche si bien dit en 90 sièges est
exclu du groupe rpr donc à l'assemblée
nationale en 97 on est dissous ouais
vous savez oui on va aller jusqu'à 98 97
ans et demi en vacances voila voila je
me représente pas ouais et je prends
deux années sabbatiques aux caraïbes
non juste à côté martin en france à
saint martin bien en france à ma ville
française vous savez kita qui va prendre
deux années sabbatiques autant les
pandas saint-martin soient ouverts
filles et entre nous la nama la bad ont
trouvé stéphane collaro carlos l'a fait
c'est le genre les gens c'est les gens
qui habitent là-bas la classe lama
johnny johnny il vient il allait lui
aussi la prise six mois sabbatiques 1 à
saint-martin et vous dirigez une radio
dans un endroit qui s'appelle mariko
soit un mélange c'est la capitale de
saint-martin ray mais c'est fou non
vous avez vraiment l'esprit et votre
soif et de la décoration
voilà alors vous revenez vous revenez
aux besoins de sympathiques vous revenez
bah oui parce que vous savez les îles
les copier tout ça c'est très agréable
généralement quand on y passe quinze
jours c'est très bien un mois c'est vrai
qu'au bout de deux ans voudrait se faire
via leur black gravure de mode
tu crois pas si bien dire c'est que
lorsque non ce que patrick revient avec
sa femme isabelle bel appartement ayant
été vendus ils sont obligés d habiter
chez leur fille
oui parce que ma fille habite à
levallois quand on est à levallois elle
nous met ses grands chez elle en mai
raciale et où elle est célibataire avant
d'accord elle est célibataire je vais
même vous dire elle vous adore la bande
quatre ans ah ouais ouais mec vos
ceintures
alors là je suis retrouvé à levallois
avec un sommet depuis arrivons ce soit
connu voilà bien à toi les employés de
mairie
j'ai beaucoup pas augmenter d'ailleurs
les employés de mairie
ce quand je suis parti y en avait on se
sent bien figurez-vous quand je reviens
il y en a 14 oui c'est quand même
extraordinaire et moi j'en utilise est
que de temps en temps
alors vous voyez il y en a qui les
utilisent pas soit 300 bugs trouvés la
ville dans quel état est sérieux un peu
dégradée très honnêtement c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs qui m'ont réélu c'est par
hasard touche pour mettre dans les
magnums non ils ont des vies long des
trottoirs sales ils ont une
leur design et leur sueur de faire
bizarre je vais vous dire ce de
levallois oui à l'aise il m'aime
beaucoup
c'est normal oui il y en a même beaucoup
qui ont voté pour moi bien entendu
monsieur moi alors je suis bien d'accord
avec vous mais voilà moi je suis né un
petit peu je n'ai jamais plus monsieur
quand je passe j'ai peur de votre ville
votre police municipale est effrayante
je vous jure ça c'est pas vu ils ont des
grandes et des dents et una ça c'est
plutôt que non je vous jure sur votre
peau lisse avec les gens qui n'ont rien
à se reprocher n'ont jamais peur de la
police monsieur regardez vous pensez que
c'est un bandit et je ne serais pas là
sinon j'avais peur en passant de votre
ville qui est le bandit vous fait vous
allez faire rire là mais pas pour le
clan regarder mon nom je jure je vous
plaint de ce que j'ai vraiment failli
mourir j'ai ça m'a toujours dégoûté ça
de passer à levallois ça se voit que
j'ai pas la gueule de valable de
levallois et à la police municipale qui
direct aux toits bien voir papier tout
ça que tu fous là non je vous jure sur
la tête de ma mère que c'est vrai la
police municipale n'arrête jamais
quelqu'un pour lui de bonne gestion de
ce cas là nadal je vous ai je vous
assure qu'elle n'a pas le droit et si
elle vous arrête pour présenter ses
papiers il faut appeler la police
nationale se s te permets de vous le
demander quand même avec des armes à la
poche et des bombes lacrymo même sens
même son impressionnant ça doit être à
chicago ou alors vous avez vu ça dans
des films de série b road à vos caméras
de vidéosurveillance mais je vous jure
c'est vrai mon sujet et si vous jure
vous êtes en train de faire rire tout
levallois serge
[Musique]
sérieusement est-ce que vous pensez que
en étant parti dans les conditions qu'on
connaît en revenant en vous faisant
élire
est-ce que vous pensez que vous aidez la
politique
en agissant de la sorte mais moi je je
ne cherche pas à aider la politique je
cherche à aider la ville dans laquelle
je travaille depuis tant d'années a
progressé à aller de l'avant
j'essaye d'aider les levalloisiens moi
j'ai fais de la politique pour aider les
autres pour servir uniquement comme vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure je n'avais pas
besoin de faire la politique
je suis né dans une famille où on avait
tout ce qu'il fallait
il y avait une affaire il y avait tout
ce qu'il fallait je n'avais vraiment pas
besoin de politiques pour gagner de
l'argent comme certains voudraient le
laisser dire blessés entendre moi j'ai
fait de la politique vraiment par
conviction et je continue à faire de la
politique aujourd'hui si je vous dévouez
finalement pour levallois
c'est pas le cas votre intérêt personnel
c'est pour la ville assad et ça l'a
toujours été et ça continuera à l'être
et mon épouse aussi votre action votre
tour votre élection pour l'image de la
politique des hommes politiques pensent
que c'est bénéfique
vous savez je sais pas si l'image des
hommes politiques est aussi bénéfique
pour moi en tout cas je marche je me
rends compte d'une chose c'est que sans
investiture je suis élu d'autres avec
les investitures de tous les partis ne
sont pas élus très bien on rallume
enfin c'est maintenant une petite
interview spéciale si vous voulez bien
en la bouche
[Musique]
bien interdits moralité est ce que vous
avez déjà appliquée dans le
porte-monnaie de votre maman quand vous
étiez petit dans le porte-monnaie de ma
maman orange est sûrement dû prendre de
quoi aller acheter à carambar ou et
l'accord de huit balles quoi est-ce que
vous êtes déjà sortis et que la copine
d'un copain j'ai beaucoup de copains
ouais un commerçant se trompe à votre
avantage en vous rendant l'âme n'ai
voulu fait remarquer oui tout de suite
ça m'arrivait sam sam arrive
malheureusement souvent je trouve que
les gens comptent de plus en plus mal si
votre côté fils de commerçants si vous
pensez à vos parents non c'est mon côté
n'être j'aime pas qu'on me rende
l'argent qui ne m'appartient pas c'est
pas l'interview mensonge en a assez non
c'est la vérité vous imaginez un jeu de
l'esprit vous avez un appartement vous
possédez un appartement votre locataire
peut plus payer le loyer c'est un type
odieux mais vraiment odieux
il ya deux enfants insupportables
voulait foot est dehors jamais non jeu
d'abord je loue pas d'appartement parce
que je
voudrais surtout pas me retrouver dans
ce genre de situation j'aime pas ça et
quand j'étais président de l'office
départemental des hlm c'est à dire 30000
logements dans les hauts-de-seine
croyez moi avant d'expulser quelqu'un il
fallait vraiment qu'on puisse pas
arriver à d'autres solutions
j'ai toujours fait en sorte que les gens
soient relogés soit aidé mis des
enquêteurs me des assistantes sociales
des pieds ou non ses moi je les fais par
conviction
rien d'autre je les fais je n'ai pas
appris et en vue de gérer de gauche même
si vous continuez comme ça mais je suis
pas de droite à ceyras couple
non non je sais pas ce que c'est la
gauche et la droite j'étais gaulliste
la gauche s'est partagé quand il ya
beaucoup d'argent c'est partagé que les
autres c'est à gueuler de payer trop
d'impôts toute la journée parce qu'on
sait que c'était interdit au courant
vous savez aujourd'hui je sais pas j'ai
pas la presse alors ça a dû changer ça a
dû beaucoup changer la gauche partagée
comment vous avez dit partager partager
le pouvoir non en ce moment en vous cite
à l'ordre du mérite pour un acte
héroïque
en fait vous n'avez pas fait vous étiez
là quand ça s'est produit et vous c'est
pas vous qui avait sauvé le môme de se
faire écraser
est ce que vous dit rien vous prenez la
médaille au contraire je la remets à
celui qui l'a fait moi je le crois moi
aussi voilà merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]